herald feldzer merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on le disait
les neuf a380 le plus gros avion à
quatre moteurs de la flotte d'air france
ne voleront plus son retraites est
prévue pour 2022 en quoi la crise
sanitaire finalement à accélérer la
retraite de l'a380 comme c'est
exactement ça il avait été décidé bien
avant la crise que on arrêterait les
3,80 parce que trop gourmand
trop cher en exploitation et finalement
un avion qui a une capacité de 850 de
passage est exploité à 550 bien s'avérer
pas rentable par rapport aux bi moteur
c'est ce que j'appelle un accident
industriel de la part d'airbus
parce que c'est un avion qui a nécessité
beaucoup de développement qui a coûté
quand même 7 milliards d'euros de
recherche et de développement et il n'y
avait pas le marché y penser avoir un
marché de 1400 appareils ils ont entendu
trois cents un peu plus c'est pas
rentable et donc personne s'y retrouver
et puis ça a provoqué aussi chez les
partenaires d'airbus les petites pme
notamment beaucoup d'ennuis parce qu'il
comptait récupérer leur investissement
avec la vente des airbus donc
aujourd'hui on passe un accident
industriel mais ça n'a pas été le
premier ça sera pas le dernier on a eu
le concorde qui techniquement comme le 3
80 était une merveille
on a eu mercure pareil qui fait pas
vendu 10 exemplaires pour air inter à
l'époque la caravelle cap a été un grand
succès et puis plus récemment l'airbus
a340 kadri moteur également et bien n'a
pas existé à l'airbus 330 le même
fuselage mais avec deux moteurs
seulement donc beaucoup plus rentables
alors est ce que ça montre également une
volonté de voler de voler plus
écologique 1 pour la compagnie air
france où c'est avant tout une raison
économique alors une raison économique
d'une part écologique parce que là pour
ça se rejoint
à partir du moment où vous consommez
moins vous n'êtes plus écologique
mais la raison principale est surtout
économique parce qu'il faut remplir les
avions c'est pas évident alors peut-être
que ces avions seront rachetés par des
low cost qui vont
la ménager envie 150 passagers mais
comme il ya le coc vide qui est passée
par là et que les gens demandent ou que
les gouvernements vont peut-être
demander un espacement avec les
passagers c'est pas du tout évident donc
sur les avions classiques retirer un
passager sur de la rentabilité sera pas
au rendez vous donc nécessairement pour
toutes les compagnies aériennes les prix
vont augmenter
alors désormais quelle stratégie pour
air france tel avion et qu'elle offre
pour remplacer justement cet a380
alors aujourd'hui on a des gros porteurs
long courriers bimoteur comme l'a350 et
en particulier la 350 tirer mille donc
grosse capacité qui se rapproche
d'ailleurs de ce coffret le 3 80 mais
bien on fera des économies là dessus il
faut à tout prix
rajeunir les flottes ce qu'est ce qui
est en train de se passer pour pouvoir
retrouver un équilibre financier
alors il ya d'autres compagnies qui ont
décidé également de ne plus faire voler
l'a380 la lufthansa malaisie airlines ou
encore qatar airways quel avenir pour
airbus avec cet avion
alors pour le 3 80 c'est derrière nous
un c'est fini on parlera plus de 3,80 à
moins que ceux qui sont les 300 qui sont
commandés en exploitation on va
continuer à veiller à les entretenir
donc il va falloir maintenir non pas une
chaîne de production qui s'arrêtent mur
au moins la maintenance avec des
rectifications à un avion ça n'arrête
jamais de vivre en quelque sorte et de
s'améliorer
donc il y aura ça et puis il y aura
peut-être des compagnies qui pourront
les exploiter en low cost quand le coc
vide sera derrière nous pour pouvoir les
remplir beaucoup plus de passagers en
négligeant les passagers affaires et les
passagers première quichon le money cash
si j'ose dire des compagnies aériennes
pour terminer est ce que ça représente
une très lourde perte pour airbus ou est
ce que le constructeur à une offre
suffisante aujourd'hui pour supporter ce
retrait de l'a380 alors tout va dépendre
de la vente de 100 concurrents est dû
surtout du concurrent américain le 787
le dreamliner qui est de 350 qui est une
merveille aujourd'hui mais il va falloir
si on dit que la préco vite ça sera le
jour d'après avec un changement de
paradigme
il faudra une vraie rupture
technologique économique mais surtout
écologique ça veut dire qu' il n'y a pas
eu de rupture depuis le concorde en gros
et bien il va falloir investir
massivement et probablement par des
coopérations internationales pour que
l'alliance va plus silencieux et
beaucoup moins gourmand avec peut-être
des carburants qui choix beaucoup plus
vertueux y compris des avions
électriques en moyen courrier
merci beaucoup gérard feldzer d'avoir
partagé votre expertise vous rappelle
que vous êtes consultant aéronautique et
ancien commandant de bord